today we are going to be introducing a
new way of measuring angles we're going
to introduce a new way of measuring
angles now if you're like me when I was
in year 11 the whole question might have
was why why introduce a way of measuring
angles we have a fine way of measuring
angles if I set a whole revolution how
many what unit do you use to measure
that and how many do you have
you'll take degrees and you say a whole
revolution is 360 degrees you're like
it's fine I've been using this for years
what's the big deal right
well the thesis that I want to put you
this lesson to justify why we're doing
this is the way you measure matters
that's it that's all I want to say the
way that you measure something the units
that you use they matter let me try to
illustrate this we have the metric
system for measuring legs weights areas
things like that right we have the
metric system but who knows what came
before the metric system say we know the
imperial system right now we especially
in like in the most of the world that
uses the metric system we somewhat laugh
at the imperial system because it
basically looks like this right you look
thought this is just rubbish on the
right hand side of the board it's
actually cuz I can't remember all this
stuff I could start at a bunch of
different places but for the length
we're gonna start with inches because I
think we know what an inch is it's about
two and a half centimeters right and
then maybe you can help me work out what
the rest of this is what's next after an
inch a foot right a foot is 12 inches
does anyone know what's after a foot a
yard is 3 feet so that's roughly it's a
bit less than a meter I think mmm don't
quote me on that does anyone know I'd be
very surprised Vidor knows what happens
after a foot soondae it starts with a
seat yeah I didn't know either I had to
look it up after a foot it's a chain a
chain is 22 sorry after a yard a chain
is 22 yards you might know this one it's
very old-fashioned but you probably
heard this way before
after a chain it's not back to foot we
were used foot before I was just trying
to not tell you this is called a furlong
for a lot of you heard have you ever
heard that word before I've heard it but
never didn't know one was a furlong is
10 chains you should know what this one
is
a mile thank you is eight furlongs and
then this one is one that I only thought
about as I only associated with the sea
that's a bit of a clue that's a long
distance is after miles three miles
gives you one league so there's a book
called 10,000 Leagues Under the Sea
now you look at this and you kind of
like hey thank goodness we don't have to
do this anymore okay the imperial system
the imperial system is well kids someone
tell me right now what's the big glaring
disadvantage of the imperial system said
again it's irregular right and as a
consequence of its irregularity it is
insanely hard to remember that's why I
well admittedly I didn't grow up in the
imperial system so perhaps if we had
grown up in that we might have known it
but it is weird and it just keeps on
going like smaller than itches it's even
more irregular bigger than leagues it
keeps on being irregular so instead we
designed the metric system right in the
metric system the whole advantage is
that it is not irregular it's it's
consistent it's regular all the way up
it's like Oh to get from one unit to the
next you're going to multiply by by ten
or a hundred or a thousand it's always
in powers of ten rather than these
random units right but what you need to
understand is that it's not like one
system is completely superior in every
way every system is a compromise for
example when you've got metric units
right some of your numbers end up really
enormous if you measure something like
say kilometers right if you're measuring
an astronomical distance or if you're
measuring a microscopic distance the
numbers are either huge or their tttd
teeny tiny so for example we had to
introduce things like scientific
notation to be able to deal with the
enormity or the tidiness of our numbers
okay now here's the thing right and you
guys haven't not like me haven't
experienced this personally but you can
see it even here on the board right the
great strength of the imperial system is
no matter what distance you're talking
about or no matter what weight or things
like that right pretty much everything
you can deal with this is going to be a
terrible illustration but you'll
remember it everything you're going to
deal with any leg
anyway you can deal with on an order of
magnitude you could say how long is that
oh it's not seven of these you just pick
the appropriate unit right or it's about
three of these and you never have to
deal with crazy insane huge numbers or
really really tiny numbers if you're
like well it's a small thing I'll just
use a small unit right and so you can
always think of these in terms of
numbers that are easy to calculate
mentally why do you think that might
have been important in an age where the
imperial system was around why do you
think mental calculation might be why we
would build our system we didn't have
any good technology right people used to
have calculators and then have to like
their gears and call - you have to like
physically crank it by hand it's like
this sucks why would we do this
why not just design a system you could
just work it all out in your head right
so here's my point every measurement
system has a trade-off right I think by
and large we're like we don't need this
advantage anymore
we have computers in our pockets right
so that's why we've as a as a world
almost moved over okay now that's why
we've been thinking about degrees right
degrees we're going to introduce this
new I want to use the word unit though
in a few lessons time hopefully I'll
explain why it's actually not quite a
unit a new way of measuring angles and
it's called a Radian our ad I a in s you
know in your calculator if I could you
get your calculator out for me on your
calculator if you go to a little borrow
your zippers okay thank you very much if
you I think you have to say shift yeah
you do if you say shift an ED mode right
which takes you to the setup you'll
notice I think it's the yeah which row
is it's like the third of the fourth row
it's the second row actually yeah you
can see three and four do you see
options three and four they are dead
four degrees and rad four radians
right now sometimes you might have gone
to that you like what what is this about
what does all this mean we don't know
what three-quarters if it does but those
two things are for switching between
degrees or radians if you want you can
make that heavier by the way radians
okay now radians are going to feel weird
they're going to feel weird the same way
when I just described the imperial
system that feels weird to us right in
the same way that the metric system felt
weird to people when people when
society's changed over from one through
the other but I promised you that
weirdness is going to be worth it
because there are some huge advantages
to move into a new kind of system it's
just not clear yet what the advantages
are let's understand the system first
and then we'll get to them